bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de Michel
Clouscard
alors il est possible que le nom de
Michel couscar ne vous disent rien ce
n'est pas un philosophe connu au sens où
on l'entend classiquement
il est surtout connu par un cercle assez
restreint au sein de la philosophie
contemporaine à savoir le cercle des
théories critiques du libéralisme
et cycloscar connaît regain de
popularité ces derniers temps
c'est parce que ces analyses sur
l'évolution de notre société
font diablement écho à ce à quoi nous
assistons depuis un certain nombre de
décennies
Michel puska est né en 1928 il est mort
en 2009
c'est un natif du Tarn qui a d'abord eu
une carrière d'athlète de haut niveau
donc on n'est pas vraiment sur le profil
type de l'intellectuel tel qu'on se le
représente
et si le nom de kluscar a fait date
c'est parce qu'il a été l'un des
premiers à faire le lien entre le
capitalisme et l'idéologie du désir
et quand on parle d'idéologie du désir
chez puska on parle de ce qu'il appelle
le freudo marxisme
le freux de marxis
de la pensée de Freud et de la pensée de
Marx
mais c'est plutôt un mouvement de pensée
qui tente de rapprocher le marxisme et
la psychanalyse
voit dans ce freux de marxisme un pseudo
marxisme
c'est-à-dire que pour lui vouloir
rapprocher marxisme et psychanalyse
c'est déjà trahir le marxisme
parce que dans l'ADN du marxisme il y a
l'idée que ce sont les structures
collectives qui façonnent l'individu
tandis que dans l'ADN de la psychanalyse
il y a un primat de l'individu sur les
structures collectives
donc pour Claus car le front de marxisme
ne peut être qu'un oxymore
mais c'est un oxymore au sein duquel le
marxisme a été pour ainsi dire absorbé
le marxisme s'est fait manger par le
frodisme
et donc dans les faits ce qu'il reste
c'est une idéologie libertaire
une idéologie basée sur
l'accomplissement du désir individuel
or cette idéologie libertaire pousse car
nous montre qu'elle est en réalité
complice de ce qu'elle prétend combattre
à savoir le capitalisme
c'est très important de comprendre ça
dès le départ
pourquoi
l'idéologie libertaire ne s'oppose pas
au capitalisme contrairement à ce
qu'elle prétend ou à ce qu'elle pense
elle en est l'auxiliaire
l'auxiliaire idéologique du nouveau
capitalisme de la consommation
dans les cercles militants il est admis
que la pensée libertaire s'oppose au
capitalisme
que libertaire et capitaliste ce sont de
termes antinomiques
c'est même l'un des objectifs principaux
de l'activisme libertaire
l'abolition du capitalisme
quand on pense aux libertaires on pense
immédiatement à l'anarchisme
à Proudhon à Bakounine Acropole
c'est à dire des auteurs qui
s'opposaient radicalement au capitalisme
on connaît la célèbre citation de
Proudhon la propriété c'est le vol
difficile de faire plus anticapitaliste
alors bien sûr il y a plusieurs branches
au sein du mouvement libertaire
il y a des spécificités il faut pas
faire l'erreur de tout mettre dans le
même sac
mais globalement ce qui unifie la pensée
libertaire c'est le rejet de l'autorité
le rejet du pouvoir
et en l'occurrence du pouvoir
capitaliste
c'est pour ça qu'il ne faut surtout pas
confondre libertaire et libertarien
je t'ai pas dit libertin
libertarien
la libertarien c'est quelqu'un qui pense
qu'il faut laisser les individus
absolument libre
y compris et surtout en matière de
marché
pour les libertariens le capitalisme
c'est pas un problème
plutôt le problème du capitalisme c'est
qu'il n'y en a pas assez
c'est que le capitalisme n'est pas
encore assez développé
être libertarien c'est donc s'assumer
comme pro capitalisme
alors qu'être libertaire c'est être
contre l'économie capitaliste
pour le dire simplement le libertarien
est favorable à un maximum de liberté
individuelle surtout en matière de
liberté économique
tandis que Le Libertaire est favorable
un maximum de liberté individuelle
surtout en matière de liberté morale
le point commun entre les deux c'est
lentilles etatisme
c'est le rejet de l'État comme structure
coercitive
comme structure qui opprime
fondamentalement les libertés
individuelles
donc dans la pensée libertaire la lutte
contre le capitalisme est adossé à la
lutte pour l'expansion des libertés
individuelles
de ce qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui les
droits sociétaux
d'où une composante essentielle de la
pensée libertaire qui est la
valorisation de la transgression
parce que la transgression est un geste
d'un soumission à l'autorité de l'État
et bien ce que nous dit que
cette pensée libertaire qui
historiquement c'est effectivement
opposé au capitalisme
on vient désormais à être au service du
capitalisme
en d'autres termes que le capitalisme et
la pensée libertaire
se confondent désormais au sein d'une
seule et même idéologie que crousternum
le libéralisme libertaire
alors il va falloir expliquer
parce que j'entends déjà des voix
indignées
on sait que la politique mobilise les
passions
et que quand les passions parlent la
raison se tait
donc que nous dit la raison selon Michel
closcar
elle nous dit que pour des raisons
dialectiques et on reviendra sur ce
terme par la suite
que pour des raisons dialectiques la
pensée libertaire la pensée libertaire
c'est-à-dire la pensée anti-autoritaire
la pensée qui défend les libertés
individuelles et la libre satisfaction
de nos désirs
que cette pensée libertaire joue un rôle
moteur dans l'expansion du
néocapitalisme parce que le
néocapitalisme repose sur un nouveau
modèle social qui est le modèle de la
permissivité
en d'autres termes le modèle social que
veut le capitalisme dont a besoin le
capitalisme
ce n'est pas un modèle répressif et
prohibitif
c'est au contraire un modèle permissif
et transgressif
pour le dire encore plus clairement le
capitalisme a besoin du désir
c'est ça le fondement de la thèse de
kuskar
et donc là on se heurte à une première
opposition
une première opposition qui consiste à
dire que si
le capitalisme constitue bel et bien un
système oppressif
un système négateur des libertés et
prohibitif sur le plan moral
en somme le capitalisme est un système
réactionnel
et là
nous remet les pendules à l'heure
parce que pour lui croire que le
néocapitalisme serait un système
réactionnaire
c'est l'erreur à la source de toutes les
erreurs
klusca remonte à 1947 et au plan
Marshall
le plan Marchal c'est l'aide financière
accordée à la France par les États-Unis
pour reconstruire le pays après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale
donc la France s'endette auprès des
États-Unis
et ce que nous dit closcar c'est que
cette dette nous n'allons pas de voir la
rembourser économiquement
nous allons devoir la rembourser
culturellement
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'en plus des dollars
livrés à la France
les États-Unis vont également introduire
dans notre pays une partie de leur
marché
en l'occurrence de leur marché du
divertissement
de leur marché du désir
parce qu'évidemment les États-Unis
pensent à leurs intérêts commerciaux
et ils savent que pour convertir une
population un nouveau marché il faut
refaçonner sa culture
refaçonner les modes de vie autant que
les modes de pensée
donc tout ce cas analysent très
méthodiquement c'est l'objet de son
livre Le capitalisme de la séduction
et nous parle de l'arrivée des flippers
de l'arrivée des jukebox de l'arrivée de
tous ces objets du divertissement qui
selon lui ont pour fonction de prolonger
le rapport au ludique chez l'adulte
le ludique c'est l'espace de l'enfance
l'enfance donc ouskar rappelle qu'elle a
pour finalité la sortie de l'enfance
c'est-à-dire
l'apprentissage de l'effort et de la
responsabilité
et tout ce remarque que les nouveaux
objets culturels envoyer par les
Américains
favorise le maintien dans l'enfant
le maintien dans la recherche du plaisir
immédiat
on ne joue pas pour gagner contrairement
au travail le travail a toujours pour
finalité de gagner quelque chose
en l'occurrence de gagner de quoi se
nourrir
on ne joue pas pour gagner on joue pour
jouer
le ludique devient une finalité en soi
et là on pourrait y voir quelque chose
de dérisoire
quelque chose en tout cas d'innocent
le fait que les Américains et introduits
en France l'industrie du ludique
mais tout ce qu'on nous dit non
c'est pas des rares
c'est pas des resoires et c'est pas
innocent non plus
les Américains ne sont pas idiots
ils savent ce qu'ils font
ils nous convertissent un nouveau modèle
culturel
le modèle culturel de la consommation
ludique
le modèle culturel de la chatte
transgressif
c'est à dire de la chatte qui n'a pas de
fonction utilitaire
l'ancienne moral était fondé sur
l'économie sur l'épargne
sur la fonctionnalité
la nouvelle morale sera fondée sur le
gaspillage
gaspillage au sens de dépenses inutiles
inutile si ce n'est l'utilité du
divertissement
et c'est ça selon tout ce car qui signe
l'entrée de la France dans le
néocapitalisme
ou plus exactement l'entrée du
néocapitalisme en France
l'entrée dans une culture du
divertissement
l'entrée dans une idéologie du désir
ce que nous dit cluscar c'est que nous
avons une vision périmée du capitalisme
et cette vision périmée nous empêche de
voir les rois véritables de la société
capitaliste
nous subissons la domination capitaliste
sans même nous en rendre compte
et nous nous en rendons pas compte parce
que nous fonctionnons sur un ancien
logiciel du capitalisme
le logiciel du capitalisme répressif
le logiciel du capitalisme autoritaire
et moralisateur
du capitalisme comme méchant
ce que nous dit que c'est que le
capitalisme n'est plus méchant
il est devenu très gentil
il est devenu très serviable
et c'est pour ça qu'il est beaucoup plus
dangereux
le capitalisme n'est plus méchant ça
veut dire que le capitalisme n'est plus
un système qui fonctionne sur la
répression morale et pulsionnelle
sur l'effort sur la privation sur la
retenue
ça c'était le capitalisme ancienne
formule
le capitalisme jusqu'au milieu du 20e
siècle c'est à dire jusqu'au plan
Marshall
mais le capitalisme a changé enfin non
il n'a pas changé il a muté
il a connu sa métamorphose
sa mutation libertaire
parce que ce n'est qu'en devenant
libertaire que le capitalisme pouvait
s'assurer le succès de ses nouveaux
marchés
marché du plaisir marcher de la
transgression
marché du sexe
regardez autour de vous
les panneaux d'affichage les publicités
les séries télé
demandez-vous
est-ce que le système dans lequel je vis
m'incite au conservatisme
ou est-ce qu'il m'incite au contraire au
plaisir
au bien-être
à la liberté
poser la question c'est y répondre
et c'est montrer que l'ancien
capitalisme le capitalisme basé sur la
morale sur la prohibition morale que ce
capitalisme là est révolue
et que nous sommes passés à une nouvelle
phase du capitalisme
à savoir le capitalisme du désir
le capitalisme est apparu grosso modo au
16e siècle
il s'est surtout développé au 18e siècle
avec les sorts de la bourgeoisie
et le capitalisme c'est l'idée selon
laquelle la société devrait s'organiser
autour d'un marché concurrentiel libre
et non faussée
que le marché doit primer sur le
contrôle de l'État
que l'État est bien gentil mais qu'il
empêche quand même pas mal la société de
se développer
et que si les individus sont libres de
commercer la société s'en trouvera
enrichie et apaisé
la promesse du capitalisme des origines
ce n'était pas seulement la prospérité
des nations comme disait Adam Smith
c'était aussi la fin de la guerre de
tous contre tous
la fameuse théorie du Doux commerce cher
à Montesquieu
et donc même si le capitalisme du XVIIIe
siècle est déjà attachée au concept de
liberté
dans la pratique le capitalisme est
d'abord associé à la notion de travail
c'est par le travail qu'on s'enrichit
c'est par la privation qu'on accumule
compte théorise comme on disait à
l'époque
la théorisation c'est l'accumulation
pour l'accumulation
on ne dépense pas
on investit même pas
la richesse pour elle-même
et surtout la retenue
on se retient de dilapider son argent
en se discipline
et ce rapport entre capitalisme et
discipline ce sera un peu la colonne
vertébrale du capitalisme durant tout le
XIXe siècle
vous avez peut-être déjà entendu parler
de Stakhanov
qui a donné naissance à la directive
stacanovistes
stanov c'était un mineur russe dans les
années 30 et un jour Stakhanov a l'idée
de segmenter le travail de ces camarades
ouvriers de sorte que chacun effectue
qu'une seule et unique tâche
c'est tout simplement l'application des
principes du fordisme américain mais en
Russie
et donc ce jour-là
Stakhanov et son équipe vont extraire 14
fois plus de charbon que sur une journée
normale
ils vont extraire 14 fois plus de
charbon que sur une journée normale en
appliquant les méthodes du capitalisme
industriel
et c'est ainsi que Stakhanov est devenu
le symbole de la réussite par le travail
alors en Russie il est surtout devenu le
symbole tu dévouement et de la
productivité
mais au-delà de la Russie Stakhanov fut
le symbole du capitalisme à l'ancienne
c'est-à-dire du capitalisme
disciplinaire qui permet de s'enrichir
par le travail
par le mérite
aux États-Unis ça donnera le modèle du
self-made
l'homme qui s'est fait tout seul
l'homme qui s'est élevé par ses efforts
personnel
et donc ce capitalisme disciplinaire ce
capitalisme de l'effort et de la
restriction tout ce que nous dit c'est
fini
ce n'est plus ce capitalisme là qui
domine aujourd'hui
le capitalisme qui domine aujourd'hui
c'est le capitalisme de la jouissance
de la libération du désir
la capitalisme de la frivolité
et de la subversion de tout ce qui
entrave le plaisir
car désormais le capitalisme n'est plus
fondé seulement sur la production
il est fondé sur la consommation
et le comportement attendu par le
consommateur n'est pas le comportement
attendu par le producteur
le producteur doit être austère
le consommateur doit être jouisseur
le producteur doit être obéissant
le consommateur doit être libre
parce que sinon il ne consomme pas
jusqu'à on dit l'ancienne moral
interdisait le gaspillage
elle interdisait la consommation à des
fins non utilitaires
le consommateur ne doit pas se demander
s'il a besoin de se produit
mais si là envie de se produire
ce qui guide le comportement du
consommateur c'est le désir
c'est la pulsion
l'ancien capitalisme interdisait
d'assouvir ses pulsions
le néocapitalisme autorise la
subissement de ses pulsions
il promeut l'assouvissement de ses
pulsions
d'où la schizophrénie du prolétaire
contemporain
schizophrénie du prolétaire contemporain
parce que dualité du capitalisme
contemporain
répressif avec le producteur
permissif avec le consommateur
rien n'est plus faux nous dit que
rien n'est plus antinomique et
contradictoire que l'idée selon laquelle
le capitalisme contemporain serait basé
sur la répression
parce que la répression c'est le
contraire de ce qui est attendu par le
consommateur
celui dont on veut qu'il dépense
on pense où on dépense
le consommateur doit dépenser
il doit dilapider ce qu'il gagne
durement par son labeur
la majorité des foyers français sont
endettés
le système de crédit
crédit à la consommation crédit
immobilier
c'est l'illustration parfaite de la
société du désir
on achète avant d'avoir de quoi payer
on consomme et ensuite on règle la note
alors la question n'est pas de savoir si
c'est bien ou mal
la question de se rendre compte que
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
dans l'ancienne conception du
capitalisme
dépenser servaient d'abord à s'équiper
s'équiper du nécessaire ou en tout cas
de l'utilitaire
parce qu'il faut bien satisfaire ses
besoins
le néocapitalisme la plus promoteur le
besoin
il a pour moteur le désir
parce que contrairement aux besoins le
désir est illimité
le désir n'a pas de fin
dans un livre qu'il a publié en 1972 qui
s'intitule néo-fascisme et idéologie du
désir
explique que contrairement à une idée
répandue
mais 68 n'a pas constitué un mouvement
de contestation de l'ordre établi de
contestation de l'ordre capitaliste
mais qu'il a au contraire été l'occasion
d'une mutation du capitalisme de sa
forme traditionnelle et autoritaire à sa
forme libertaire et permissive
alors mai 68 ça fait partie des sujets
clivants
donc pour certains mais 68 c'était un
mouvement très positif
un mouvement qui a permis de moderniser
la société et de la libérer du poids des
traditions
pour d'autres mais 68 c'est le début de
l'anarchie
de l'anarchie au sens péjoratif
au sens de désordre
mais 68 c'est la destruction des normes
la victoire du sexe
la victoire de la transgression
mais dans un cas comme dans l'autre on
ne parle que de la dimension sociétale
de Mai 68
et pas de sa dimension sociale
et ça c'est révélateur
mais 68 ça a été la plus grande grève
ouvrière de l'histoire de France
10 millions d'ouvriers dans la rue
c'est pas rien
pourtant quand on parle de Mai 68 on
parlera rarement de la grève des
ouvriers
on parle de la libéralisation sexuelle
on parle dit il est interdit d'interdire
un slogan du reste éminemment libéral
bref on parle du Mai 68 étudiant
pas du Mai 68 ouvriers
le mai 68 étudiant représenté par la
figure de Daniel Cohn-Bendit
et d'ailleurs ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que Daniel Cohn-Bendit déclara
lui-même en 1999 je suis un libéral
libertaire
alors même que kluscar avait écrit dès
1972 comme mai 68 avait représenté
l'avènement en France du libéralisme
libertaire
kluscar prophétique
kluscar qui avait compris dès 1972 que
le devenir naturel du capitalisme
c'était le libertarisme
que le devenir naturel du capitalisme
c'était l'idéologie du désir et de la
transgression
parce que sans idéologie de la
pas de nouveau marché du désir
l'ancien capitalisme on l'a vu tout à
l'heure était fondé sur les notions
d'efforts de travail et de discipline
ça n'a rien d'étonnant
ça n'a rien d'étonnant parce
qu'historiquement le capitalisme repose
sur l'éthique du protestantisme
je vous renvoie à l'ouvrage fondateur de
Max theber l'éthique protestante et
l'esprit du capitalisme dans lequel
Weber montre bien qu'il y a dans la
culture protestante une éthique du
travail et de l'enrichissement
dans le protestantisme
l'enrichissement matériel ce n'est pas
un objet de honte
c'est au contraire
un signe de grâce
et la répugnance à l'effort est un signe
d'absence de grâce
dieu veut que nous soyons heureux sur
terre et le bonheur sur terre ça passe
aussi par l'enrichissement
c'est la grande différence entre la
vision protestante de l'enrichissement
et la vision catholique de
l'enrichissement
dans la vision catholique s'enrichir
c'est alourdir son âme
c'est alourdir son péché
parce que les premiers seront les
derniers
parce que les mieux pourvu ici-bas
seront les moins pourvus dans l'eau de
la
le catholicisme n'est pas culturellement
adapté au capitalisme
le protestantisme
laid donc sans rentrer dans les détails
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que jusqu'au
milieu du 20e siècle le capitalisme
fonctionne encore sur le principe de la
répression pulsionnelle et de la
prohibition morale
et après mes 68
ce principe se renverse
ce n'est plus la répression qui est
encouragée
c'est la dispersion
ce n'est plus l'utilité de la
marchandise qui est recherchée
c'est sa capacité à procurer de la
jouissance
et à signifier son appartenance sociale
ben oui parce que quand on dépense tout
son argent dans des futilités
c'est qu'on n'a pas besoin de se priver
ou de faire attention
donc la bourgeoisie ne se caractérisera
plus par sa sobriété
elle se caractérisera par sa frivolité
le frivole est très sérieux nous dit que
le frivole signifie quelque chose de
très sérieux
il signifie une appartenance au classe
privilégié
et Mai 68 c'est le moment où le
capitalisme intègre la frivolité comme
sa nouvelle composante essentielle
on l'a dit tout à l'heure ce qui a
conduit le capitalisme a passé de sa
forme ancienne à sa forme nouvelle
ce qui la conduit à passer d'une éthique
de l'effort à une éthique du désir
c'est le fait que le capitalisme
d'autrefois était un capitalisme de la
production
tandis que le capitalisme nouveau est un
capitalisme de la consommation
auparavant on produisait pour satisfaire
ses besoins
dorénavant on consomme pour satisfaire
ses désirs
et autant le producteur doit se plier à
une éthique répressive
autant le consommateur doit se libérer
dans une pratique permissive
on incite pas à consommer par une
éthique de la modération
on incite à consommer par une éthique de
la séduction
par la mobilisation des passions
la publicité et la meilleure
illustration de cette nouvelle éthique
du capitalisme
on vend du rêve
je vous invite à aller voir le face à
face télévisuel qui a lieu sur le
plateau de l'émission apostrophe entre
Michel cuscar et Jacques Séguéla
c'était en 1982
et à l'occasion de ce face-à-face
a bien mis en évidence que le discours
du publicitaire
c'était en réalité le discours du
sophiste
de celui qui persuade indépendamment de
la vérité
de celui qui persuade par la séduction
alors qu'il était en train d'analyser le
rôle du publicitaire dans la société
capitaliste nouvelle
kluscar s'est vu reproché par Jacques
Séguéla de prôner une vision totalitaire
de la société
parce qu'il osait remettre en cause
l'idéologie du désir comme levier du
capitalisme marchand
c'est ça le tour de force du libéralisme
libertaire
faire passer toute critique de
l'idéologie capitaliste pour une
critique de la liberté
la publicité vend de l'imaginaire
elle vend du symbole
c'est à dire du futur
et elle fait passer le futile pour une
valeur première
étymologiquement futile ça veut dire ce
qui fuit
ce qui laisse échapper ce qu'il contient
quel meilleur métaphore du désir
on pense évidemment ici au tonneau des
Danaïdes
le fameux tonneau percé
ce tonneau verset qui représente
allégoriquement le désir humain
la futilité c'est la forme du vide
et ce que dit que l'Oscar face à Jacques
Séguéla c'est qu'il est le représentant
du vide devenu un marché
substituer le désir au besoin
ces données au marché une étendue
maximale
on avait parlé dans un précédent épisode
d'Edouard Bernays
celui qui a voulu ouvrir le marché du
tabac aux femmes et qui pour ça a eu
l'idée de faire de la cigarette un
instrument symbolique d'émancipation
une femme qui fumait ne fumait pas
elle se libérait de la domination
masculine
elle se libérait du poids des traditions
de cette tradition qui l'a dissuadé de
succomber à ses désirs et donc de
devenir une cible du marché
ne dis pas que la tradition est une
bonne chose
mais il constate que le néocapitalisme a
besoin de détruire la tradition
on en revient à ce que disait Marx sur
le caractère révolutionnaire du
capitalisme
Marx nous disait le capitalisme ne peut
se développer qu'à condition de
bouleverser constamment tous les
rapports sociaux
je vais vous lire un extrait de la
présentation du livre néo-fascisme et
idéologie du désir
c'est Aymeric Monville qui écrit Aymeric
Monville c'est l'éditeur actuel des
oeuvres de kuskar aux éditions Delga et
il écrit je cite derrière cette revanche
de l'individuel contre le collectif il
faut voir la main du pouvoir économique
et de l'OTAN la bourgeoisie a voulu
s'emparer de la lutte révolutionnaire à
travers un renversement simple les
nouvelles luttes sociétales doivent
remplacer les luttes sociales ce qui
revient comme en aperçoit aujourd'hui à
mettre la charrue avant les boeufs la
libération des individus est
conditionnée par le mouvement social de
fait un curiotroc s'opère la bourgeoisie
l'âge du lest sur le terrain des mœurs
en échange de la libéralisation
économique coup de génie des médias
bourgeois qui confondent la dynamique
révolutionnaire de mai 1968 et
l'idéologie 68 hard alors que la seconde
apparaît comme la contre-révolution de
la première contre-révolution d'ailleurs
réussi les étudiants comme prévu ont été
amenés à rediriger le pays le mouvement
ouvrier a été réprimé conspuée par les
médias privés de ses organisations
historiques les travailleurs ont été
exploités licenciés délocalisé la
social-démocratie libertaire à triompher
et donc je disais au début de cet
épisode que si la pensée libertaire
était devenue le moteur du
néocapitalisme c'était pour des raisons
dialectiques
et là j'aimerais expliquer brièvement ce
que ça veut dire pour des raisons
dialectiques
pour des raisons dialectiques ça veut
dire pour des raisons liées à
l'évolution de l'économie et aux
transformations du marché
et c'est très important de comprendre ça
parce que bien souvent quand on critique
le libéralisme libertaire les
libertaires anticapitalistes pensent que
c'est à eux qu'on s'en prend
il pense que c'est une manœuvre
détournée pour disons-le vite critiquer
la gauche
en se faisant passer pour des
anticapitalistes
il y a même un mot qui a été forgé pour
décrire ça ça s'appelle le
confusionnisme
le confusionnisme ce serait la tentative
de promouvoir un discours réactionnel
tout en se faisant passer pour
anticapitaliste
et c'est là qu'il faut être absolument
clair
ceux qui voient les choses ainsi
ne comprennent pas le concept de
dialectique
il ne comprennent pas que l'histoire est
que l'économie et dialectique
et que par conséquent
les idées politiques et les théories
critiques
sont aussi dialectiques
lorsque le capitalisme s'appuyait sur
une idéologie traditionaliste et
répressive
il était logique et cohérent de
critiquer cette idéologie
traditionnaliste et répressive en tant
que composante du système capitaliste
mais dès lors que le capitalisme ne
s'appuie plus sur cette idéologie
traditionaliste et répressive
dès lors que désormais il s'appuie sur
une idéologie libertaire et permissive
il est nécessaire de le dire
parce que sinon on combat un système
sans combattre ce qui le rend possible
on combat un système sans comprendre ce
qui le fait fonctionner
sans comprendre c'est rouages ces
mécanismes
c'est de la posture
seulement de la posture
il ne suffit pas de dire que le
capitalisme est un système basé sur la
prohibition morale pour que ce soit le
cas
or le problème c'est que
l'anticapitalisme libertaire n'a
toujours pas fait sa mise à jour
et que ceux qui ont fait la mise à jour
sont axés de confusionnisme parce qu'ils
n'ont pas fait
ça marche pas
quand le capitalisme n'était pas
mondialisé mais étatique
capitaliste de s'opposer à la nation
quand le capitalisme n'était pas
libertaire mais réactionnaire
c'était anticapitaliste de s'opposer à
la tradition
quand le capitalisme n'était pas
permisif mais prohibitif c'était
anti-capitaliste de s'opposer à la
morale
mais le capitalisme est devenu
libertaire
parce que pour imposer ces nouveaux
marchés du divertissement il a eu besoin
d'individus soumis à l'idéologie du
désir
il a eu besoin de consommateurs
de des penseurs
c'est à dire d'une population qui
s'alliait par le désir
s'abandonne à la pulsion pour mieux
s'abandonner à la marchandise
je cite
mais 68 témoigne de la plus remarquable
manipulation idéologique de
l'après-guerre celle qui assurera le
passage de la vieille France à la
Nouvelle France du libéralisme sauvage
en mai 1968 un psychodrame s'est joué au
sommet de l'État il révéla à l'évidence
les enjeux de l'histoire incarnez selon
trois rôles mythiques le père sévère de
Gaulle l'enfant terrible comme mandit le
libéral des bonheurs Pompidou c'est
l'affrontement des trois situations de
la bourgeoisie des trois systèmes
idéologiques possibles en scène la
vieille France vertueuse
issue de la victoire sur le fascisme et
d'autre part la Nouvelle France qui se
cherchait et qui s'est accomplie dans la
synthèse d'un libéralisme au combien
répressif dans l'acte de produire et au
combien permetif dans l'acte de
consommer il a donc fallu l'alliance
sournoise du libéral et du libertaire
pour liquider le vieux qui a dû s'en
aller après ce meurtre rituel du père a
été accordé au sommet par l'État la
permission du permis CIF qui a donné
accès au marché du désir ainsi en est-il
de l'ordre nouveau les trois principes
constitutifs et antagonistes de la
France ce sont en fait hypocritement
réconciliés dans un commun reniement des
valeurs originales la production
capitaliste gérée par les politiciens de
l'alternance et de la cohabitation et
consommer selon le modèle libertaire
cela s'appelle aussi la fin des valeurs
de l'histoire et dénégation de la lutte
des classes le marché du désir de
l'interdit du nocturne à métamorphoser
le marché officiel légal juridique selon
trois déterminations capitales en lui
adjoignant tout un nouveau système de
profit en lui servant de vitrines
publicitaires de promotion
libéralisation des mœurs en lui
injectant clandestinement des normes
capitaux ainsi a pu être sauvé certes
d'une manière relative et provisoire une
économie en crise
aussi la conscience humaine moderne
s'est-elle structurée selon la
contradiction du libéralisme tellement
celle-ci était et demeure oppressante
c'est le nouveau statut de l'aliénation
avant les trentes glorieuses la société
était organisée on le sait selon cette
dualité classe ouvrière exploité et
bourgeoise potentiellement ou réellement
consommatrice les uns produisaient sans
jouir les autres pouvaient jouir sans
produire le déferlement des nouvelles
couches moyennes à bouleverser cette
répartition conflictuelle de classe
maintenant le conflit aidant les têtes
intériorisé c'est la nouvelle structure
de la conscience et de l'inconscient car
ce sont les mêmes qui tantôt travail et
tantôt consomme selon les
incontournables modèles de
l'exploitation du travailleur et de la
permissivité du temps libre de la
consommation libidinale ludique
marginale tantôt esclaves tantôt maître
du monde alors s’opèrent un dédoublement
schizophrénique une causalité folle pour
jouir je m'exploite moi-même jeu est un
autre mon contraire mon patron cette
névrose objective couronne la
libéralisation des mœurs le néo fascisme
sera l'ultime expression du libéralisme
social libertaire de l'ensemble qui
commence en même 1968 sa spécificité
tient dans cette formule Tout est permis
mais rien n'est possible
dénoncer les structures du pouvoir
suppose de s'en donner les moyens
et d'aller jusqu'au bout
de ne pas s'arrêter à une critique de
surface
à une critique qui nous fait passer pour
un rebelle
alors même que la rebellitude
fait partie de la stratégie du système
quel meilleur système de domination que
celui qui se fait passer pour sa propre
négation
combattre le capitalisme ce n'est pas
seulement
dénoncer les inégalités
dénoncer les milliardaires
dénoncer ceux dont on sait
que nous critiques ne les atteignent pas
ne les effleurent même pas
combattre le capitalisme
c'est dénoncer tout à la fois comme le
faisait Marx
l'infrastructure économique
et sa superstructure idéologique
dénoncé
les rapports de production matérielle
autant que les rapports de production
spirituels
la matière et l'esprit
mais c'est surtout
entendre que nous sommes tous
partis prenantes de ce système
que nous le subissons tous
autant que nous le nourrissons tous
le pouvoir aurait disparu depuis
longtemps
si tous ceux qui prétendaient le
combattre le combattait effectivement
on a beau se prétendre anti capitaliste
ou anti-système
nous sommes les produits de ce que nous
dénonçons
nous sommes les enfants
de la bête sauvage
que nous combattons
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]